sembra un essere vivente schifo che è
stata la roba
ciao a tutti ferrari solite torres ha
grandissima grandissima richiesta nuovo
video in cui vedo di slam però in questo
caso potrà vedere il mix live cinetiche
tra l'altro che non ha prodotto
tantissimo che è colpa t
[Musica]
allora il primo mi andrò a vedere e
questo trasparente con un giorno dentro
poi andremo a vedere questo che in
pratica era un mix di bari poi questo
chi se la ricorda se potete fate della
storica e lì da tanto tempo
vi ricorderete la mostra in correzione
[Musica]
poi però non ci possiamo vedere quello
magnetico che lo ricordate
whitney lasciate un bel live
se volete vedere altri video per la
serie guardo le cose rabbit copione
scrivetemi pure nei commenti cosa volete
che guardi al microscopio le idee belle
vi lasciano ancora chino e
male anche perché io mi diverto troppo
brusco devo dire una cosa e velocemente
prima di iniziare siccome so che mi
formazione che si commette mi direte
all'interprete successo all'occhio non
sono note portato non lo sto mi sono
svegliata col tipo e questo pomeriggio
al barone di si è compiuto
[Musica]
vedere e quindi non so se ma cultura ma
bensì spero che passi presto perché di
sapere se voi mai successo che cos'era
[Musica]
stesso entrati vestiti riccò di patatine
pop corn e giù subito
ok ragazzi iniziamo con il primo questo
e quello yuriko non più
scusate e fichi quindi cache tennis più
personaggio del ricordo allora proviamo
prima tra brillo
a osservarlo allora vediamo un fatto di
parti lucide si pronuncino disse un
impero tipo di progetto elisa un po di
sporcizia sopra
ok tiriamo fuori dal è rimasta
abbastanza buona comunque non si è
sciolto e rimasto trasparente e c'è
tutto un correre
siamo detti per il processo dei belletti
e trasparenti per essere del tavolo come
fa
vediamo il mio unico uscita riconoscere
che parte del ricordo questa sera la
bocca poi alla vita e video video volete
dire quale di riassetto di piccole di ha
scioccato di più che quant anticamente
poter vedere la mia impronta digitale
quasi è rimasta stampata di slime delle
bolle come lo rischiate sacre mille
bolle quindi che può dire che questo
schlein si è conservato molto bene è
rimasto molto carino la consistenza è
buona non puzza quindi devo dire che se
confermato poco fa bene con slime 17
volevo dirvi se comprate schede cinesi
stare sempre molto attenti in generale
vi sconsiglio di incontrare slime
canneti perché potrebbero avere dei
degli ingredienti classici che da con
volete depurati
non mi sembra quello che vedevano già
anni fa che è stato ritirato dal mercato
perché aveva degli ingredienti tossici
quindi se vi comprate protette
festeggiare a mente la base sempre le
mani dopo che si giocate non mettete le
mani in bocca e ha fatto qualche suono
che su sky e state sempre molto attenti
se vedete che si è che è andato a male è
stato un guanto per giocarlo po per
giocarci
io dopo questo video mi numero perdere
le mani per osimo slime questo che era
una sorta di klein smoothie era
mischiato degli slide quindi vediamo
infatti le vediamo prima di superficie
che strano sembra che con la superficie
della luna e grigio con tanti crateri
come lui e tutti soprattutto se si ha
nessun verme con dentro come nell'altro
a tantissime comunque era felice un pelo
ma
colorato sicuramente non sarò beni ma
sono pezzi di tessuto comunque della
maglietta quasi un pezzo gialloverde di
lucro ma che comunque sapere che cos'è
tutto è come la mostra vissuti quindi un
pezzo di colore è rimasto maniera non so
cosa stia per un insetto strano abbiamo
creato noi che diamo è rimasto incollato
di questi archetipi scusate se avete la
conosci ma è buffo piano in inglese
tremo fobia forse in italia non sono
sicura che mi danno fastidio tutti i
cerchietti attaccarti probabilmente
questo video la fascino anche se non
sono tutti andati comunque che charlene
klein e veramente strano best live o
qualsiasi sembrano antico bellissimi ma
c'è un brillantino
non voglio toccare aiuto poi con sé un
pezzo di slide giallo che se miss che
molti per circolati crateri che stanno
un po di sla
le promesse superficie molto schivo qua
e come si è staccata dalla ciotola
[Musica]
statici sembrando rotta dunque mette
debole tipo perché troppo interessante
se qualcosa di nero però che sono degli
obiettivi che ti dentro a cattivo spero
di no ma non penso che resterò a
crescere dentro lo slargo in uno scavo
strato che vi sto chiudono sembra così
il suo slang diciamo che se conservato
anche se anche un po strane dentro tipo
qui prossimo saremo andiamo a vedere lo
slime scorreggione e va allora non so se
me lo ricordo
oggi ciò che è successo possa far
bardate si è creata tipo una pellicola
vediamo
per scopi io sono pellicola che sta da
un plastico
ha vissuto il camola
il fattore viii tipo un tratto questo
slam ha fatto un trasloco di non so
[Musica]
diciamo che prima era il triplo di
quanto non so come sia successo ma etico
evaporato e youtube cicor quindi
purtroppo non fa più i suoni che si
trova questo slide vediamo larghi a
microonde anno microscopica scambiò con
allora questo fratello è una falsa tales
la rosa lucido ma niente qualche pezzo
di tessuto e sporcizia
in questo strano che la consistenza e
short sono due polizie passi sta
muovendo vedete quindi questo live
mi dispiace che sia mezzo morto è
rimasto più poco però vabbè ha fatto un
lungo viaggio quindi sicuramente per
quello a dire band scorreggione che
ricorderemo per sempre made flight cross
che mandiamo
l'am macarons non so se ve lo ricordate
mimì live unboxing no anche quattro
pellicole quindi occorre che anche
questo sia scompare siamo così
magicamente non può come ha fatto
vediamolo anche quando però la pellicola
di plastica tra sporcizia chi si è stata
la roba sacco di roba dietro non ha per
niente un bell'aspetto per gli angoli
pellicola allora c'è lo slide realtà
aspettiamo dal momento che è molto meno
il suo tiro ma perchè tante schifezze
dentro altro tipo eletti
fate non solo per i mari sarebbe un voto
più golosi 0 qui c'è festeggiarlo di
qualcosa veramente questo finale il
tifoso chiediamolo fuori o perche poche
frasi ingrid un sacco mandante si è
indurito tantissimo prima e dove se
stessa
guarda che sembra supercross al
microscopio molto spesso poi ma ci sono
piccoli mini progetti città lì sembrava
sembra di colpo di mare come onde la
società sta dentro tra sigift così
sembra il cuore l'acqua di una piscina
oppure di una spiaggia super azzurra
dall'altro slime è una ci manca l'ultimo
un po paura dell'ultimo perché quelli
magnetici bene quindi per l'ultimo
siccome anche quelli magnetici sono qui
sappiamo vetro vado a usare di quanti ok
ragazzi pronti
ecco qua lo slime in questione se non lo
avete visto quando l'ho aperto vi lascio
alla fine questo video il link che
linked in questo tipo ma anche ho aperto
così diretto come erano prima anche
comunque rapidissimi funzionava
benissimo non mi ricordo se il magnete
l'ho lasciato dentro
ora vediamo allora cosa serve del
vincolo si era incollato e ha un aspetto
un po strano sinceramente prima non era
così non so se sia penso che si stia un
ufficio prima era capito anche grigio
sono mi sbaglio se ora c'è questa parte
bianca strada che investiamo sul sicuro
andiamo a vedere microscopio così
sicuramente è molto particolare questo
slime adesso al mondo contatti che si
tratta sembra super twitter app e
striature con questo bianco che pensate
però che le stesse parato dall'altro
limpido ma cazzo e facciamo guardate
questa bolla c'è stato questa palla
è striata praticamente alle striature di
quotidie argentate benissimo ma ci sono
altre strutture che è successo master
ventura cambino e lamenti dentro
proviamo a tirare rumori e puliti amo
inedita in merito però tira fuori nello
in quanto il contatto tra l'altro quindi
si sa si è coinvolto circa la vitale
giovedì scorso vederla vedere qualcosa
ingrandito tenete questa razza la vita
cercando di toglierla
[Musica]
questa è riuscita a vederla è difficile
perché è comunque ancora magnifico
questo strike quindi schiatta comunque
ancora centra dello slang attaccato quel
che lamentato ancora lo slime poi
torniamo vediamo se riusciamo a vedere
avete visto
entrano sempre di più guardate come si
avvicina troppo strano vedere per
vicinissimo sembra un essere diverse
scusate che sta scattando bellissimo da
vedere utilizzi un morto tanti strumenti
per gq piede destro bellissimo certo
rate compri la costruzione in pietra
quel crisi auguri non sia mezzo hanno
scritto su un solido che è successo
l'effetto sapete che per ora resterà
l'ultimo slime io mi sono divertita
troppo non so perché quello che cosa
capisco che mi rilassa tantissimo e in
cui avessi un stato quindi fatemi sapere
nei commenti se volete vedere altri
video come questo cosa volete che guardi
al microscopio e mi raccomando lasciate
un like ora vi lascio 4 capelli né su
cui potete clickare prevedere i prossimi
video e se volete vedere i miei miti
divertenti illegale
niente video microscopio chicca su
quella che preferite e buona visione